Ivik:
Og så skal du egentlig bare svare på spørgsmålet efter bedste evne, og du skal ikke trykke på noget.
Det er først til næste opgave næste opgave.
Ivik:
Så forestil dig at du er på gangen.
Det er den 27. februar.
Ivik:
Og du kommer i tanke om, at du gerne vil booke et mødelokale mellem 14:30 og 15.
Så derfor går du hen til nærmeste mødelokale, og her lægger du mærke til at tabletten foran mødelokalet viser noget på skærmen.
Ivik:
Og det første spørgsmålet er egentlig, er der på nuværende tidspunkt et møde i gang i lokalet?
Per:
Et hvad?
Ivik:
Et møde i gang i lokalet.
Er der nogen der har et møde i lokalet på nuværende tidspunkt, hvis du kigger på skærmen?
Ivik:
Kan du se det?
Per:
Kun mellem 12.13.
Ivik:
Ja, lige præcis.
Hvem har booket det her møde?
Ivik:
Kan du se det?
Per:
Det har Mia.
Ivik:
Ja. Kan du så sige, om lokalet er ledigt mellem kl 14:30 og kl 15?
Per:
Øh, ikke mellem 13:15 og 14:15.
Ivik:
Nej. Og hvad med 14:30 til 15, er det ledigt der
Per:
Ja.
Ivik:
Super.
Okay.
Ivik:
Så skal jeg lige have skiftet billede her.
Yes.
Ivik:
Dette scenarie her det går du så videre til... *fumler med ordene*
Så du konkluderer egentlig, at det lokale, du var i, ikke er tilgængeligt, det tidsrum du ville holde møde.
Ivik:
Så derfor går du hen til lokalet ved siden af, som også er et mødelokale.
Og så er spørgsmålet egentlig, er det her lokale ledigt?
Per:
Lige nu?
Ivik:
Ja.
Per:
Det er den.
Ivik:
Hvornår er det næste møde i det her lokale?
Per:
kl 13.
Ivik:
Yes.
Og er det muligt at booke lokalet mellem 14.30 og 15?
Per:
Det er det.
Ivik:
Super.
Det var nemt.
Ivik:
Du var faktisk bedre end Ole han var.
Nu kommer anden halvdel, og det er her hvor vi egentlig vil give dig nogle opgaver som du skal løse.
Ivik:
Jeg skal lige sige på forhånd, at der er nogle ting, vi allerede har fyldt ind.
Så du skal egentlig bare lade som om, eller vise os hvor du vil trykke for at udfylde de her informationer.
Ivik:
Så det kan godt være at du trykker og at der ikke sker noget, men det er bare så vi har en indikation af, hvor du vil trykke ind for at gøre det.
Så det her er egentlig din første opgaver.
*rækker ham et stykke papir med opgaven skrevet på*
Ivik:
Du må gerne læse opgaven højt hvis du vil.
Per:
*Han trykker på det blanke feldt ud for host for at vælge værten.*
Ivik:
Og her skal du bare trykke på scan QR koden.
Patrick:
Så på selve QR koden.
Ivik:
Ja.
Og det er egentlig bare fordi, at vi har ikke lige lavet en version hvor du kan sætte en vært ind, men det er bare en prototype det her.
*Ivik trykker på QR koden for at scanne den.*
Ivik:
Så nu har jeg sat den der på.
Det vil så selvfølgelig være dig, kan man sige.
Per:
Der står, med Ole. *(Han skal tilføje Ole i opgaven)*
Per
Der står Mia her.
*Peger på værten af mødet*
Ivik:
Ja.
Så i virkeligheden så skulle der stå Per her, fordi du er vært, og du vil gerne invitere Ole.
Per:
nååh.
*Trykker på invite. Trykker derefter på Oles navn for at invitere ham. Til sidst trykker han på confirm*
Ivik:
Ja.
Præcis.
Ivik:
Super.
Godt.
Ivik:
Så skifter vi lige billede her.
*Ivik skifter til occupied skærmen*
Ivik:
Og så får du en nye opgave.
Per:
*Læser opgaven*
*Klikker på extend*
Jeg kan ikke lige huske, hvad tid...
Per:
Nå, det var mellem det her.
*peger på et møde på tidslinjen*
Per:
For at 30 minutter mere, så...
*Trykker der hvor man kan vælge slut tidspunktet.*
Patrick:
Yes.
Per:
*Trykker endnu en gang der hvor man vælger slut tidspunkt*
*Prototypen lader hende ikke vælge tiden*
Nå.
Alle:
*snakker i munden på hindanden*
Per:
Det er så der jeg kan ændre den og så confirm.
*Peger på slut tidspunktet*
*Peger derefter på confirm*
Patrick:
Bare tryk på confirm.
*Per trykker på confirm*
Patrick:
Yes.
Ivik:
Sådan der.
Super.
Ivik:
Og så får du lige et tredje opgaver her.
Per:
Ja.
*Læser opgaven*
*Trykker på "End meeting"*
*Bekræfter derefter at afslutte mødet*
Ivik:
Super.
Ja.
Ivik:
Det var så tit bare det.
Så lige her afslutningsvis så vil vi bare lige høre dig, var der er noget du synes der var godt?
Ivik:
Eller, hvad var godt ved det her?
Per:
Jeg synes det er nemt.
Ivik:
Så det er nemt at få et overblik over hvordan det...
Per:
Ja, fordi man kan se her hvornår den er ledig.
*Peger på timeline*
Ivik:
Ja.
Og modsat, er der så ting, som du synes, der ikke var helt lige så gode?
Per:
Noget du tænker at det kunne være bedre?
Nej.
Per:
Altså, jeg kan godt lide det.
Ivik:
Du kan godt lide det.
Per:
Altså, jeg har ikke prøvet at booke møde før,
men det der med at man kan gå op til et møde lokale,
Per:
og så se hurtigt om der er ledigt og man kan booke det.
Ivik:
Ja.
Per:
Også at de næste også kan se, hvornår den er ledig.
Ivik:
Ja.
Per:
Jeg syntes den er nem at bruge.
Ivik:
Okay.
Det er vi glad for at høre.
Ivik:
Jamen, jeg håber, at det var til at overleve, og at vi var ordentlige ved dig.